there's a very good chance that if
you're watching this video and you are a
person who lives in the year 2023 you
don't have as much money as you probably
want to have it's difficult times right
now I've always been pretty good at
making money I've always found a way to
somehow acquire money but I've always
been horrible at keeping it no matter
how much money I made I always found a
way to live paycheck to paycheck somehow
like I just couldn't figure out how
people accumulate wealth and that is
until first year of University when I
read this book called the richest man in
Babylon I'd have one earbud in in my
down time at work listening to the
richest man in Babylon and I remember my
mind slowly being blown and it
completely shifted my mindset towards
how money even works and it really acted
as the Catalyst the game changer that
shifted the trajectory of my financial
re reality and helped me end up where I
am today so I want to share with you
guys some of the key takeaways that I
learned from the richest man in Babylon
so that hopefully by the end of this
year you will have more money in your
bank account and your financial future
will end up looking a lot more
optimistic so the only way that you're
going to work your way out of financial
misery is if you stop falling for the
biggest money mistake what is the
biggest money mistake well it's not this
cute little thing it's not this little
mistake that you know haha silly me it's
so much bigger than you think so let me
paint a picture it's kind of the only
way of understanding it let's pretend
that you are a little kid again you're
nine years old and you really lucked out
because it's your full-time job to play
Chuck E Cheese games you go to Chuck E
cheese you play whack-a-mole you drain
the Hoops shoot the guys I don't know
what you do at Chuck E cheese I haven't
been there since I was nine years old
but that is now your full time job as a
nine-year-old you work there all day
nine to five Monday through Friday and
at the end of each day you're given the
Chuck E cheese tickets and as a
nine-year-old you're probably very
excited you're thinking man I'm making
so much damn ticket money I can afford
all of these cool prizes at the Chuck E
cheese prize counter your entire mind is
occupied by this it's occupied by the
amount of tickets that you have and what
you can purchase at the prize counter
with the tickets that you have everybody
in the world is playing this game with
money we are all in Chuck E cheese we
are under the illusion that we are
getting paid with Chuck E cheese tickets
and the only thing to do with the Chuck
E cheese tickets is to buy Chuck E
cheese prizes but when you think this
way you are living in The Matrix you are
not aware of the fact that you're
actually getting paid in cash and you
can step outside of Chuck E cheese and
spend money on whatever you want you
know it sounds overly simple and kind of
ridiculous when I put it this way but
this is exactly what keeps people
financially
stuck it's because they slave away for
ten dollars an hour eight hours a day
forty hours a week at the trinket shop
and then they come home we start
thinking about all these cool trinkets
that we can buy with our money that we
earned from working at the trinket shop
and this is extra Sinister because the
trinket shop actually makes more money
off of you than you make off of them
because when you work at the trinket
shop you are worth more than ten dollars
an hour to them otherwise they wouldn't
pay you you would be a net loss to them
so for all of the time and effort and
sweat you invest into the trinket shop
they give you a little bit in return and
then you somehow fall for the ruse and
convince yourself to give the money
right back to the trinket shop by buying
trinkets everything that you watch on
the TV when you get home every billboard
that you see on your drive home from
work is just talking about trinkets
again ooh look at this little trinket
you can buy even though you just spent
all day serving the trinket shop and the
trinket owners here give your money back
to the trinket shop that's how you get
uh
the question is how do we break free of
this cycle there's only one way really
and that is to pay yourself first this
is one of the biggest takeaways from the
richest man in Babylon if you pay
yourself first you make ten dollars from
working at the trinket shop every day
just take one this one is for you and
for you alone okay you take this you put
it in a different account first and then
you use this to buy trinkets do whatever
the hell you want with this you got to
pay rent right you know rents like all
of it there's like internet and phone
bill and you're out again but at least
you paid yourself first ten percent may
sound like such a small amount but if
you save ten percent you will be doing
more than most people do most people
don't save anything because they feel
like they can't but in reality most
people have a Netflix subscription a
Disney Plus subscription blah blah blah
right and they go to Starbucks bucks or
they go to Tim Hortons here in Canada
McDonald's everybody manages to
Hemorrhage money it's because if you are
an average person then you fall right
into the demographic of buying things
that you don't need your money is going
to go to the Emperors of the world no
matter what it's just gonna happen it's
the way the world is structured but if
you pay yourself first you will find a
way to save a little bit on groceries a
little bit on coffee human beings are
super adaptable if you learned that okay
next month you're going to make 90 of
what you normally make you would find a
way to make it work you always do you're
still here we are survivors and we're in
a situation economically where you
really have to bet on yourself because
nobody's going to do it for you it's
crucial that you pay yourself one dollar
for every ten dollars that you make you
put it into an account that you cannot
and will not spend on anything other
than things that can potentially yield a
return we'll get into that later but at
the very least it sits in an account
that you don't touch you don't waste it
away on everything else that money is
for you it's yours and yours to keep
okay so let's summarize what we've
learned so far and then let's move on to
the next most important thing number one
so we're not at Chuck E cheese number
two is that the only way to escape the
nightmare of the trinket shop tyranny is
to pay yourself first then the next most
important thing is to increase your
ability to earn once you've gotten into
a habit of continually saving as much as
you can paying yourself first before you
pay anyone else then the only way to
increase your wealth or increase the
rate in which you accumulate this stack
of cash that you have and you don't
touch is to increase the income coming
in so how do you do that the easiest way
is through education now I don't mean
you have to spend four years and tens of
thousands of dollars getting a college
degree because we live in in the
information age there are so many
marketable skills that you can learn
online for free without the need to pay
a cent like a perfect example of this is
video editing so I know a guy who I know
quite well I might even be watching this
video and be like hey that's me he just
learned video editing basically this
year you know dabbled a little bit in
the past and it led to you know a four
to six month stint working as a video
editor for some company and now he has
that on his resume and now he can go get
another video editing job people want
things that are popular video content is
extremely popular you'll learn how to do
Photoshop you can pose as a thumbnail
expert people are hitting up my DMs all
the time saying hey do you want YouTube
shorts people pay money for that kind of
thing you know you look around you
you're here on YouTube you're watching a
video Someone edits video someone makes
videos be the guy who knows a little bit
more than your average person on how to
produce video content and boom you have
a job job that's in demand learn how to
do things okay learn how to make things
how to build things and monitor what
you're consuming with whatever you input
into your brain on a daily basis you
have to ask yourself is this helping me
grow is this helping me expand my
expertise and my usefulness to the world
and the value that I can add to people
or is it just keeping me distracted and
entertained because the bar is so low
like if you don't fill your time
constantly with Tick Tock and YouTube
you are so far ahead of the pack in 2023
just find ways to just not be on these
platforms all the time and you're well
ahead of everybody else and then have
the added upgrade of educating yourself
on you know how how certain creative
things work how to start copywriting
maybe how to leverage AI to make
creative content stick your finger in
the air analyze where the wind is
blowing start working on what what's
popular and figure out more about it and
you'll be surprised as to how many
people want to pay money for people like
you who know what to do and also ask
yourself and reflect on what is
occupying your mind like what are you
excited by motivated by and that might
sound like meaningless mindset gobbley
but it really is everything what
you are preoccupied with and excited by
reveals what your incentive structure is
you know are you excited about the new
Bethesda game that's never going to come
out or are you excited about Financial
Freedom spending time with people you
care about you know your spiritual
well-being your social well-being like
where is your mind at because the
answers to these questions often reveal
where you're gonna end up months and
years down the line okay before we dive
into the next takeaway I just want to
give a big thank you to Audible for
sponsoring this video and I'm extremely
excited excited that this video is
sponsored by audible specifically
because an audible subscription is
exactly what I'm talking about in terms
of like a high value return on
investment like instead of spending the
exact same amount of money on your sixth
streaming service subscription where you
can watch 68 episodes of a poorly
written show that's going down the
gutter why not spend that on something
that gives you access to some of the
greatest insights ever recorded you know
audiobooks like the richest man in
Babylon that will get you thinking about
ways that you can change your financial
situation and for those of you who don't
know audible is the leading provider of
spoken word entertainment and audiobooks
all in one place every single month you
receive one credit which you can spend
on any audiobook of your choice
regardless of price and you get to keep
that audiobook forever and you also get
access to a rapidly expanding catalog of
audible Originals podcasts and exclusive
Series so if you're in interested in
joining me in becoming big brain and
expanding your mind then if you use my
link in the description below or text
better ideas to 500 500 then you'll get
a free 30-day trial and also in August
I'll be going live here on YouTube
discussing the Charisma myth so if you
head on over to audible or if you
already have an audible account download
the Charisma myth because we're going to
be talking about that on the channel and
uh I think it'll just be a really good
time it's the first time I'm doing
something like this here on YouTube so
once again head on over to audible.com
better ideas or text better ideas to 500
500 to get your free 30-day trial thanks
again to Audible for sponsoring this
video oh hey Joey from the future here I
totally forgot to film this part uh so
here we go as we talked about earlier
you save your money right so as you're
Escaping The Matrix you're starting to
develop this pocket of wealth for
yourself you're saving one dollar for
every ten dollars that you make so that
you're slowly making your gold pouch
fatter what do you do with it do you
just let it sit there well you know
what's funny is if you did nothing else
and you just let the money sit there and
you didn't invest it you didn't let the
money work for you you would still be
doing so much more than most people most
people don't save anything but I do want
to say that saving while it is so much
better than not saving it's also the
second worst thing you can do with your
money
the worst thing is to not save at all
the second worst thing you can do is to
just save it and do nothing with it and
the reason why that's bad uh well I mean
it's good but the reason why it's not
optimal is because when your money sits
in the bank you actually lose money over
time I mean you gain money over time
assuming that you're you know saving it
but you actually lose a lot of money due
to inflation year after year because of
inflation your dollar even though the
dollar amount is constant the dollar
value the weight of the dollar is going
down over time it's inevitable so you're
actually losing money you're slowly
leaking it when it sits in the bank
another important point to make is that
when your money just sits in a savings
account in the bank it's not actually
sitting in a savings account in the bank
right this isn't the olden days where
you had sacks of gold and you gave it to
a bank and it's just sitting there you
know you can open up the Vault again and
take your money out whenever you want it
what's actually happening is you're
loaning your money to the bank and the
bank is doing what you should be doing
with your money but they're doing it
instead and that's how they make a
profit that's how the banks make money
is they borrow your money and they
invest it and grow the money and they
say oh yeah you know what we're just
paying for security so when you want
your money again you can take it out but
that's not always the case you know the
Great Depression proved that if you ever
if you've ever seen the movie uh It's a
Wonderful Life you know there could be a
bank run and you can't take your money
out the bank goes sorry we lost all of
your money because the economy crashed
you can't do anything about it so I
think that's why it's crucial that while
it is better than nothing to have your
money sitting in the bank
you should start learning how to invest
and I will never give you investment
advice because I'm not an advent I'm not
an expert but I will give you just a
vague idea of what I'm doing essentially
what I do is I diversify right so
instead of having 100 of my money in the
bank I'm currently building a property
uh where property value is high I
understand not everyone has the luxury
to do that but you know I'll at least
have some land that I can call my own
that has no mortgage on it
um I really want to get into buying some
gold you know some actual you know
tangible things that are out there as
well as put money in index funds and
whatever in the States you have 401ks or
whatever but the the point being is that
the only way that you're going to learn
how to invest is by investing you're
going to lose your money uh because
you're not a pro at it but the richest
man in Babylon has a lot of great advice
advice about seeking advice you'll start
to gain a lot of wisdom about evaluating
the types of people that have the
highest probability of helping you out
and giving you Sound Investment advice
and sort of making yourself immune to
it's too good to be true type situations
get rich quick schemes
are schemes the only way to get rich
quick is to offer genuine value to
people
to help people out you either have to
help a lot of people solve a small
problem or help a few people solve a big
problem and if you really luck out you
help a lot of people solve a big problem
but it's not as easy as it sounds so if
you want to get rich you know maybe you
help a few people solve a big problem or
a medium-sized problem maybe you invest
in a pressure washer for five hundred
dollars maybe you knock door to door on
people's doors because you knock on
doors when you go door to door and you
say hey I notice your driveway is really
dirty I'll pressure wash it for a
hundred bucks and they'll say oh 100
bucks that's super cheap or they'll say
100 bucks that's a ripoff my driveway is
super small you never know until you try
if you pressure wash four driveways
during the summer then you pay for your
pressure washer back
see investing doesn't always have to be
into the stock market there are ways
where you can invest in yourself you
know maybe you buy two pressure washers
three pressure washers maybe you start
charging two hundred dollars you start
paying a friend to help you with the
pressure washing company you take a
little bit of the cut because you
invented the company and you scale you
know there's so many ways to invest in
assets that will make you money you just
have to be creative and you have to be
engaged and you have to fill your mind
with good ideas from you know audio
books YouTube videos online courses
talking with people who are
knowledgeable you know start occupying
your mind with inventive ideas and then
go and take action on them that's the
most important thing so step one like I
said be aware that you're in The Matrix
step two or Chuck E cheese or whatever
step two is to escape Chuck E cheese
start paying yourself first developing a
little money patch on the side that's
growing and growing and grow
and adding and adding and adding and all
of a sudden while you're living a very
similar lifestyle it's a lifestyle 90
similar to how you were living except
the only difference is that you have an
accumulation of wealth growing and then
with that wealth start educating
yourself on how to make the money work
for you diversify so you're not just
keeping everything in the bank maybe
this is stuff you've heard a million
times before but if you are an average
person you're not doing it statistically
you're not doing these things so really
start with step one and step two and
step three it doesn't have to be perfect
but the enemy of good is perfect
perfect is the enemy of good
something like that take care guys if
you're investing let me know in the
comment section below what you're
investing in are you banking everything
on crypto on a niche coin that you're
hoping blows up why is that not a get
rich scheme I want to know these things
I want to learn from you guys hopefully
this video gives you some ideas that you
know hopefully it just simplifies things
for you personal finance does not need
to be super complicated if you do the
basics and you nail the basics you're
doing so much better than most people
but most people fail at the basics and
then they look for the super complicated
get rich schemes while they're
simultaneously hemorrhaging money due to
Lifestyle inflation and they're never
saving anything or paying themselves
first or developing any kind of wealth
in the background so nail the
fundamentals and then go to the
financial Experts of YouTube and try to
find the best way to help your money
make you money other than that though
guys thank you so much for watching this
video as per usual and I have a favor to
ask of you if you are on Instagram
anyways please follow the better ideas
Instagram because I really want to start
a podcast and I want to get the highest
quality guests possible but my presence
is so small on Instagram because I
barely use it and um you know I plan on
using it more but when I slide into
people's DMS that I want to talk to you
know I just get ignored because I have
like no presence on Instagram so merely
as a tool to help me reach uh
interesting people go ahead and follow
me on Instagram at better ideas so that
I can secure the coolest most badass and
interesting
um guests on the secret podcast I am
developing other than that guys good
luck if you're in a bad financial place
it can get better no matter how bad the
economy is around you there are always
outliers people who can change their
situation through hard work and
determination and just the right
information you know maybe you've been
given bad information and hopefully this
is kind of simplifying things for you
and gives you encouragement to help you
develop wealth slowly but surely so that
you can escape whatever situation that
you're in and if you think I'm
completely oversimplifying things fair
enough let me know why in the comments
section below
um because yeah I'm not a finance guy so
maybe I just have a terrible take on all
of this but um you know these overly
simple methods are working really well
for me recently I just find that
simplifying things just works better for
my brain so let me know all of these
things looking forward to talking to you
guys in the future
and uh stay hungry I don't know what do
I usually say that's all for today thank
you so much for watching and we'll catch
you in the next video